من سيقبض على بوتين وكيف بعدما اصبح
مطلوبا للعداله الدوليه بدعوى ارتكابه
جرائم حرب وبامر من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
المحكمه ذات الولايات القضائيه العالميه
تختص بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن جرائم الحرب
والاباده الجماعيه عندما لا تستطيع
السلطات الوطنيه القيام بذلك وهذا في
الدول 123 التي وقعت على معاهده انشائها
روسيا ليست واحده منها ليس للمحكمه شرطه
او قوات عسكريه
وتعتمد على السلطات المدنيه في اعتقال
وتسليم المطلوبين قرارات المحكمه تواجه
اشكاليه تتمثل في رفض الدول تسليم
المتهمين
اشكاليه واجهتها في تسليم الرئيس السوداني
السابق عمر البشير اذ رفضت عده دول موقعه
على ميثاق المحكمه
التعاون في اعتقاله بما في ذلك تشاد
وكينيا ويعتبر الرئيس الروسي ثاني رئيس
تصدر بحقه مذكره اعتقال وهو على راس عمله
بعد البشير
واقتصرت بقيه المذكرات على قاده عسكريين
ومسؤولين ارتكبوا جرائم حرب في الحاله
الروسيه يمكن اعتقال بوتين في حالات
محدوده كان يغادر بلده الى دوله قد ترغب
بتقديمه للمحاكمه او ان تسلمه سلطات بلاده
وفي بلد يتمتع بوتين فيه بسلطه مطلقه فانه
من غير المتوقع ان يسعى الكريملين الى
تقديمه للمحكمه الدوليه
المذكره لا معنى لها يقول الكرملين بينما
ينظر اليها الغرب كاشاره من المجتمع
الدولي الى ان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا مخالف
للقانون
وبين هذا وذاك لا احد يستطيع القبض على
بوتين